five star  let's go to mr del mar wait what was the  nail  my hair it's too perfect it looks too  good  it's so hard to be seen by scott's  camera because of your hair  i do feel a little weird oh  was it because i spanked your bottom no  [Music]  mommy yep oh i didn't think y'all say  action  [ __ ] my bad  i do wonder where we're all going to  live though  but this has been  um  my toes stopped growing after i was  three months old i'm not kidding they're  like little pieces  [Music]  i'm sorry i'm sorry of course i have my  resume  [Music]  oh my god barb star the topic is socks  [Laughter]  your stomach doesn't care where you are  it just  releases  you could be in the market or in the  parking lot at the dry cleaners  just goes sorry  day  [Music]  [Music]